ladies and gentlemen
oh [ __ ] here
[Music]
[Music]
all right well we're live in full effect
so you know when it gets messed up
what's up y'all merry christmas
man i'm just doing a few live episodes i
don't got my podcast room set up yet
i'm doing it at my chair i want to have
people come but i haven't had a guest
yet
and i don't even have rachel because i
have to get this all set up
i just want to come on and do my podcast
welcome
welcome to real world
[Music]
okay yeah everybody what's up what's up
chat
how i hope y'all doing good let me get
my let me get my music ready for
when the super chats come in and this is
remember my matic productions
beats i got my matic productions beats
my boy
he makes he made some dope ass beats for
me i have a bunch of them but i just
thought i would use these
for this right now to have a couple of
good beats so when them super chats come
in you know
in the middle of no matter where they
are in the podcast
here we go
you know hit you with that dad [ __ ]
[Laughter]
anyways guys so let's get into it
and uh by the way this episode is
brought to you by better help that's
better
b t t e r help h-e-l-p better help
and i'll talk all about that later uh
that's if you need some therapy and some
counseling
uh better help will help you out and see
that right there we starting off with
um
thank you sir
anyways so let's get into it some of the
things i wanted to talk about today
should i do a christmas recap first
let's do a christmas recap um i don't
know how it is this is like i just moved
i moved on the 19th
so nothing was set up i really don't
even have
i didn't have a christmas tree i had no
christmas lights my girlfriend's jewish
so
christmas is all about me i don't got
kids yet so there's nothing to really
even be
what is christmas really you know
christmas is nothing without people to
share it with
uh maybe that's harsh for people that
are out there alone but
it is what it is i mean guess you could
self-love you could love yourself get a
treat for yourself
make sure you get dinner for yourself
make sure you treat yourself nice
but that's a good thing to do during
christmas you know what i mean i got
some water right here me get some water
but i mean for the most part though like
when you think of christmas and you
think of
gifts and presents and and the lights
and all this kind of stuff you know
that's about
you know family that or or or loved ones
even if it's like
chosen family even if it's like not even
like your real family but just some
friends of yours you know
you should that's what christmas is
about so like you know for me
and also you get to a certain age when
you're a dude of a certain age you get
over 40 you get over 45.
christmas you're not getting nothing man
nobody's giving you gifts nobody cares
about you
you know and and then i tried to explain
to rachel's like
she don't understand that i say
christmas means like i like being
surprised if you're gonna get me a gift
give me a gift
but she made it all about like what do
you want what do you want me to do
like like what do you want me to get you
and it's like just do you know me
like the best kind of gift saying about
the money it's about like if you know
somebody if it's
special you know you make it special for
that person
you know what it whatever whatever it is
you know like if
like it's like let's say you're into
elephants or something you know and like
you have a lot of elephant artwork and
elephant pictures and sculptures
so even if i go to a place and i find
some little elephant thing and it's only
15
but it's you know it's nice like you
know you know it means something and i
give
that to you you're like oh man you got
this little elephant thing for me so
it's like it's about that so
you know when you're with somebody and
you know them you know
giving them a good gift is about you
know giving them something that you you
you letting them know hey you know what
i really know you
you know i know you and i think that
you're really gonna like this so but she
didn't get it
[Laughter]
so she had already got so but i got her
something you know
and she don't even really celebrate
christmas but she likes getting gifts
you know but we all do right
then she got me a face mask that's what
i got this year for christmas y'all i
got a face mask
a nice one you know it's like a plastic
you wrap it around it feels good on your
head
but i was like really but my buddy jeff
honda had best friends for like 20
something years
jeff got me the ancestry thing the you
know the so you can find out
where you are who you came from i don't
know if i want to do it honestly
i don't know how you guys feel about
that what about you guys in chat tell me
how you feel about that you know since
we're doing this live and if you guys
listen then you can put in the comments
and
or send me messages like what do you
like i don't know if i
wanna really know where
all my ancestors are from i don't know
if i want to know that is it important
to know that
or is it more important to like this is
how i grew up this is what i was told
this is what i see
you know so i don't even know my family
is i have such a
mixed background you know from
central america
from belize and honduras and
jamaica and i have all these family
members from all these different types
of things and so it's like
you know you see my aunts my aunts are
like they look one of them looks like
oprah you know i mean they're
they're like dark-skinned black you know
my mom's fair-skinned like me i look
more like my mom never met my dad before
so i don't even know what who knows what
that ancestry is
and so you know i've always i look at
my mom's side of the family and even
even even she's estranged from
her she's not even full with her family
who is this part of the family i'm
talking about who is darker skinned
you know so like you know i always
identify as black
but it's probably like 20 you know 20 25
but in the united states that's all you
really need for people to treat you
like you know look at you treat you
funky
you know what i mean i always say
there's only two types of racism
there's only two races white and
non-white
in in the united states i feel like that
you know it's like
if you're white okay you have the
privileges of being white or whatever
people identify oh that guy's white
and then when you're not white they're
it's always like a well
whatever box or category they're trying
to put you in so whatever my
percentage i am i don't know if i want
to actually know and see this and be
like oh damn
i've thought of myself as this for so
long do i want
that to be shattered or is it does it
even matter you know what i mean
so that's my question to you guys in the
chat right now and for people listening
you know does it matter
you know what i mean does it matter so
you know i don't know you know and even
if you're white by the way
you know there's so many different i
mean
what i said about only two races is that
i don't i don't that doesn't mean that's
right either i just think that's not
thinking that people have because
even if people are white you have people
who come from scotland and ireland and
england and germany and you know there's
people that come from all over the world
that have like a fair-skinned look and
they're even people from spain who are
more
relations to people who are in latin
america but they they sometimes look
like they're white so it's like
even just being white you have like this
sub-sect of being white but like you
know in the united states we just look
at things we just go well it's like you
know there's white and there's white
privilege and this is white white white
white
you know and then everybody else is like
whatever you know or it'll be like okay
you're black
you know and then or you're latino or
you know but then even that
has like you know if you're from mexico
you don't want to be called el
salvadorian if you're sovereign you
don't want to be called from guatemala
and it's like
we have all these like categories that
we put ourselves in and it's
freaking crazy so anyways i don't know
if i want to
i don't know if i want to be like get
definitive proof and it comes and it
says oh we're actually you're this
and you're your dad's family from here
and your mom's origins from this
i was going to do a show i was gonna
host this show it was it was about this
it was about the it was about the
genetic test you know
and they um sorry that's i don't know
why rachel's texting me right now in the
middle of my damn
podcast you know what i mean
you know um i don't i and so anyways
let's get back to this so i was going to
do this show and i was going to be the
host and what they were going to do was
they were going to get people say
somebody was racist
or somebody that had some like bad
feelings towards basically racist
whatever but that was gonna be one of
the things like
you take some guy and you give him his
ancestry and you he comes to find out
that
he's actually from all different types
of places and there's some people
there's some races in there that he you
know and how does he how does a person
deal with that
or you know you're going to find out
some information about
your own family that you didn't really
know but anyways i'm not being clear but
it doesn't matter because we didn't even
do the show there was a lot more to it
but anyway the the lady that the
producer she was telling me her own
story so i'm
just going to tell her story because i'm
not saying her name so it doesn't matter
but she was saying that she always had a
problem with her mom
her whole life you know like they they
had a really bad relationship
her whole life so in preparation of
doing this she was going to take the
test herself right so she takes the test
and then she comes to find out that
she's like
let's say german and something else i
forgot what the two things were
and when she saw that she knew something
was up because she knew her mother was
from
such a place and her dad was from one of
those places
so then she goes to them and she's like
so she sees that
that her her mom
is not from any of these places that the
test did right
so she goes to her family her parents go
hey what's the deal
and then the parents reveal that it's
not her real mom
and whatever the story was but way back
when she was born how they dealt with it
but then it made sense now because you
go oh well this is why
you hated me my whole life or or
whatever it is you know
so so in that case maybe it's good you
finally know the truth but in other
cases you go
maybe it's better like to not know maybe
like you know maybe it's like
this is what i've identified with this
is how i've grew up
and i'm fine with this like knowing this
information like what is it going to do
is it going to change your mind so
i don't know what do you guys think you
know do you do you people listening
people watching
putting comments you guys that are
watching live i mean is it important to
know this information is it truly
important to know
what your ancestors are from
after you've been when you're like
living in the united states now for your
whole life you're not even from
you're not even from that place anymore
you know nothing about it you haven't
lived any traditions or anything for it
is it important to know see a lot of you
say you don't really care
i don't know i'm at a point where i
don't really care like i've never met my
dad before
and i honestly don't care i never have
it not that i don't care it just it
doesn't bug me
i don't know you guys out there i've
never i guess it would be
terrible if like you've never met your
dad oh let's say you were like you knew
your dad
and then at seven years old your dad
leaves so you have this memory of your
dad for me seven years old and he just
leaves
then you're like damn my dad's gone and
that would hurt but if you've never
ever had a dad i don't know what i'm
missing until i see
other people though i had a good buddy
of mine that you know we just we're not
friends anymore
and you know i would tell him i told him
once i said hey
uh you know your dad
when i see your dad and you and your dad
interact it makes me realize oh this is
what having a dad is like and so
being around being around him made me
feel like oh wow that's what that would
be like you know what i mean so
but that's the only time i really think
about it like i don't i don't miss it i
just go oh well look
is that what that's like so i've never
had a dad and it's never
it bugged me because i remember even i
remember going to my mom and being like
mom
tell me about this i was young i was
like younger than i am now let's say i
was like
like you know in my early 20s or
something like that i remember saying to
her like hey what's the deal
and then she got a little sensitive you
know like but yeah you know i raised you
you know and then you go uh oh
something's going on here you know what
i mean
it's like you know you you it's like you
find out the truth and now you're going
to be like or you know because women
have their secrets and it's okay
your parents had their secrets actually
you don't know what was going on in
their lives before they had you they all
kinds of things were going on and
happening
so i don't know her story and i don't i
don't i'm not mad at her about it
even if it was let's say even let's say
my mom even it was her fault let's say
he wanted to be in my life and she was
like no
and she was being bit whatever i still
love my mom i'm not gonna be madder
about it because i
understand it people go through things
and that's that's on that's all then
and there's nothing i can do about it
now either i can't get it back i can't
get the 40 plus years back of like
having a relationship my dad's probably
dead for all i know because if i'm
with the age i'm at he and he was older
than my mom
you know what i mean so it's like he's
probably 100 or 90 something years old
so i probably have brothers and sisters
out there for all i know i don't know
but anyway she told me his name
no i'm not drunk you know that's a
stupid thing to say so
i'm doing this live i'm putting this
fool on timeout
live you know what i mean so when you
come and you say
dumb stuff you get put on time out so a
few people listening
if you ever want to watch live know that
i am looking at the chat
and when i see something stupid you out
[Laughter]
anyways so i
so my mom tells me she tells me some
information
gives me his name you know and then i
remember like she goes if you want to
find out do
you research on your own and i was like
oh okay so then like three weeks later
i hadn't done any research and and i
realized
and i had forgotten his name and at that
point it didn't
really matter to me
anymore you know that was the test to
let me know that it didn't really matter
but uh oh oh guess what
you know that's crazy
like patrick's crazy
rapping on it it's lit
when you give that super chat
[Music]
thank you for the 25 super chat
get with it y'all all right what else is
going on guys let's talk about
i want to go into who saw wonder woman i
you know i saw a wonder woman i love
listen we just came off of marvel
the marvel universe it took like 13
years starting with iron man
captain america and all this and they
and they gave us this wonderful story
with like you know really fantastic
actors
some really great movies some okay
movies
but overall the fact that they combined
the universe it really
set a tone for what we want from like a
movie universe basically you know what i
mean
you know the the mcu you know so it was
great
so dc is trying to catch up and they're
like you know what and they failed
dc pretty much failed at this right
justice league was terrible
all the movies they try to do they keep
losing superman now the guy's back they
keep changing batman's
you know it it's unbelievable all right
but let's go to wonder woman so the
first
like the first wonder woman so wonder
woman 84 just came out
so the let me go back the first wonder
woman i thought that was a great movie
i thought it was a great origin story i
thought it was you know
she's great gal gal gadot is that her
name except for singing imagine she's
pretty good
i love she's
first of all she's gorgeous okay she's
but she's a great actress too she's
compelling to look at
i love her accent i love like how she
makes it work
you know with the story she's compelling
you know like i believe her
you know what i mean like i believe
everything that she does and says in the
movie
i believe that she's wonder woman okay
so let's just give her kudos for that
and the first movie was great and chris
pines he's great he's a great
action comedic actor as well as being an
action type star guy
so he was a great casting and they had
great chemistry and the first movie was
great
like i thought that in the first movie
you know that scene in the first movie
where
like there's that big field and it's
called the nomad no man's land because
no man can get across it
and then she like that's the first time
she takes off her coat and she's like
well i'm going to do it you know and she
puts her wonder woman thing on and then
you know slow motion walk across the
field
i remember in the theater being like
yeah get a wonder woman you know
and it was uh it was it was just that
was just a great
thing and the special effects is great
and i love the music
you know what i mean so i love the um
the special effects because it's like it
reminds me of like a sort of
austin powers james bond spy type movie
uh you know you know something you know
something cool is happening you know
what i mean
so and it's great special effects like
kudos on the special effects
and again you believe that she's doing
it you know i i love all that right
so the first movie was good it ended
great but then
everything around with wonder woman in
the movies sucks
you know like so then you put her in
justice league and she's the best thing
in it
but the story sucks you know
it's just everything around is terrible
but standalone movie
okay it was it was probably one of the
better action movies better superhero
movies
i'd put it up there right it was good
all right so now this this new movie
comes out okay
and i'll say this i thought that the
acting performances by
three the three main people were better
than
the story and the movie hands down
by far so pedro pascal who plays the
mandalorian
that dude's fantastic i gotta tell you
man
he's so good in this movie he makes the
movie bad
because what he's giving to the movie
and giving in these moments you go oh
this is too much for
this movie this movie's not deserving of
this performance
um you know i just
i i don't like he was like that at the
end of the movie he's like
he has this moment with his son and
you're just kind of like wow this guy is
because in your mind you're going man
this this guy's really
really acting well like he needs to tone
it down this movie's not good enough for
this
you know but he's such a tremendous
actor so kudos to him for this
and some of the things that was
happening in the movie like her the
wonder woman herself gail goodell
i hope i'm saying her name right she was
great
like this choice that she had to make
spoiler alert if you haven't seen it but
spoiler she has to make well
i'm not going to say but she has to make
this choice
and i believed it was a hard choice for
her and that you know and she oh man she
has this dramatic
walk away you know and you know it was
good
and then chris pine again he's a great
actor too man you know
he he he he has this sort of selfless
role
and it was good but let me just get into
this this story
convoluted as hell like i'm not with
this story
i don't get the story i don't know what
is happening in this
it doesn't it it doesn't even make
logical sense that this
happened one in within
the dc universe too and now i'm gonna
get to that because that's my real
problem
but just overall overall give the movie
like a b-minus
because i mean like the action was great
and
this story was good enough you could
follow the story but you just weren't
you weren't overwhelmed you know you
weren't like wow that was great you know
wow i want to watch that again
but okay here's my main
big ass problem with wonder woman
so wonder woman doesn't age
she's amazon her father's zeus
so she's got god-like powers you know
what i mean
she doesn't age so she's been around for
a while
all right the first time we saw wonder
woman we saw wonder woman in
superman vs batman
okay that's the first time we saw her
all right
but obviously she's been around because
lex luthor
had that picture of her that we that we
later find
is in the wonder woman movie we find out
where that picture was taken
and she's trying to hide her identity
that's the what they're implying
in the movie all right so we first see
her in superman
first batman okay the um
now when they finally see her dressed up
as wonder woman
batman and superman are like who's that
you know batman's like
you know i thought she was with you okay
then cut to we see the wonder woman
movie
and we see justice league where she's
now involved with batman and superman
and all this stuff
now 1984 just now this
wonder woman 84 is supposed to have
happened in 1984.
so if we're to believe that within the
dc universe that they've created
batman ben affleck is 50
or he's in his late 40s still being
batman
so that would mean that in 84 he was
like
in his 20s right is that is that math
right so 84
94 2004 2020 right
so third you know so he's like late
teens okay
his father and mother have already been
killed all right
he's already like on the path of
whatever
you know he knows he's on this path he
may not be batman yet but he's on the
path
in 84 you mean to tell me
that nobody knows about this dime piece
that was
swinging around with a magic rope nobody
remembers her
nobody remembers wonder woman from 84
when this catastrophic thing happened
and so that isn't carried over into the
other part of the universe
like he would batman would know exactly
who she is there'd be more pictures of
her
than just that picture that you know she
tried to
to to to hide now
they tried to imply in the movie like
she's in the mall right
she's in the mall she's flying around
with her lasso and she takes off her
little headband
and she throws it and she breaks the
cameras that's to let us know
she was hiding her identity but all
these witnesses
like people would have been talking
about it oh you had a chick with the the
miniskirt
and the magic lasso fine she fine
there's no way that batman wouldn't have
record of that later and be like
oh yeah you mean that time he was at the
mall and you like through the thing but
they all they got footage of you before
you
threw it and there's like a hundred
thousand witnesses
you know what i mean like what are you
doing with the universe man
like it's it's like we can't
our brains we can't allow that see i had
this same problem when i was watching
marvel movies too
so we know when it was avengers or the
captain america movies
like later they had more money so then
like all the characters would be in all
the movies thor and all these people but
in the early
times like i remember thor the shitty
one
the second thor where's everybody
like thor is fighting some power we
already know that everybody knows
everybody
so where's iron man at but we know as a
movie viewer we go oh yeah cause they
probably didn't get
uh the dude to play iron man and so it
would be too expensive
that's where your mind goes because in
your mind you're hey you guys can't
connect the universes you can't connect
all these people in all these movies
and then just like let some catastrophic
thing happen and not everybody be like
yo what's up with that where's uh you
know like where's the hulk
you know what i mean where's black widow
uh where's uh you know where's all these
people you know what i mean
like it just it don't make no sense so i
feel the same way about
this dc universe they're creating this
is the same wonder woman that's in
justice league this is the same wonder
woman that was in batman superman
how in the hell they don't know who she
is if she was flying around
in 84 look you know how they could have
handled this
they could have handled this by once the
main dude renounced
his dream his wish what it should have
done was
reset the universe back to when they
found the thing
if they would have done that then they
would have wiped away everything that
happened
in this movie then i would be okay with
in 30 years
batman don't know who the hell she is
you know what i mean
so i don't know man
yeah i i just i don't know how you guys
feel about it
you just reminded me about something i
want to talk about chat
i just i don't get it you know what i
mean i just i don't i don't get it
and i hate that kind of stuff i mean i
harp on little nonsense like that i'm
i'm crazy like that you know
i'm crazy like that wait but before we
go
before we go on we got
another super chat uh uh
[Applause]
thank you sir thank you for the super
chat
um so i don't know so i guess overall my
i just really want to see what they're
going to do with the dc like are they
just going to reset the whole thing
now this new batman trailer i saw the
batman trailer and i was like
oh wait that looks good batman looks
good i can't wait to see that
but this is like supposedly like early
on
he just became batman so he's been
batman for like three or four years
and this is what's going on there so it
looks dark it looks menacing and i love
it i can't wait to see it we love the
batman story
but i don't know how that's going to
connect later to if they're going to
continue this justice league and all
this stuff
because right now wonder woman like they
see they need to do
what marvel did they need to do it with
one like with captain america so like in
captain america those became really
avengers movies
you know like captain america civil war
everybody was in it
captain america uh universal soldier new
york universal soldier winter soldier
remember universal soldier with
jean-claude van damme but
winter soldier that was an avengers
movie too in my opinion so
um we'll see you know
what this is gonna mean for
you know like are they gonna continue
the justice league and i believe the
dude is playing batman harry kavezel is
that his name
i i mean i mean i'm sorry superman he
like left the series
but then i thought i think that the
people the powers that be they were like
dude we can't replace superman again
like we already got people
thinking that this dude superman we
can't just have this go away
so they probably went to him and said
come on man what we got to do how much
money you need
how much money you need we'll give you
the money you got to be superman so
and i hear he's going to be superman
again you know i yeah harry
kavit let me let me see you know
um still
super man let's see what they're saying
on on
isn't hanging up his superman cape just
yet sources confirmed to provide that
the man of steel actor is talks to
return as clark kent in the upcoming dc
comics
movie dc comics movie
warner okay there you go
so yeah he is coming back
you know so it just it just it just
makes sense and he did a good job i
thought he was a good superman
what do you guys think you know i
thought he was a good superman
so we'll see how that goes
uh oh guess what y'all
[Music]
fine
[Music]
hairy chorizo that's what somebody in
chat said harry chorizo
that's like the spanish superman that'd
be funny
all right before i go on guys next week
i'm gonna be back i'm doing uh we got we
got new year's coming up
and i'm gonna do my last real world
advice from a grown ass man
coming at you next week um so we're
gonna do that so if you have those
questions make sure you look out for my
instagram post
for real well device from a grown ass
man
but before i do that i just want to tell
you guys that
like i said earlier i have a new sponsor
of the show so i always do
when i do the real world advice i always
get people that they ask me really great
questions but sometimes people ask a
question that i go
you know what i'm not a professional
therapist or anything like that i'm just
giving you advice but sometimes people
like have like
serious issues and anxiety you could
tell by the nature of the question that
you need help and so i always recommend
i say get some therapy
go out you know go find out find someone
to talk to somebody because
it's important to really help you
organize your thoughts so because of
that i think i have a new sponsor and
it's called better help
it's better help
betterhelp.com griffin will get you
a percent discount for richard mcgriff
and users and this is a sponsored
portion of the show
uh better help um he looks like i say
therapy is important you know because a
lot of things interfere with your
happiness
uh you know stop you from achieving
goals if you feel listless and
sluggish and you you feel like man what
what am i doing right now or
if things become too much is something
preventing you from achieving your goals
like
better help will assess your needs and
match you with
a licensed professional therapist this
isn't self-help
this is actual therapy you can send a
message to a counselor at any time and
they will get back to you
they get back to you with the timely
thoughtful responses look these licensed
professionals they handle all kinds of
things depression stress relationships
sleeping lgbt issues grief self-esteem
you name it they take care of it
in fact so many people have been using
better help
that they are recruiting additional
counselors in all
50 states i want you to start living a
happier life today as a as a listener
you'll get 10 off your monthly
by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
griffin betterhelp.com griffin the link
is below
join over one million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
and again guys that's better help dot
com
slash griffin h e l p
help betterhelp.com griffin
check them out today i strongly
encourage you to do this
i myself have gotten therapy and it is
such a
it's it's it really helped me organize
my thoughts
and pointing me in in the right
direction towards
really taking charge of the things that
i felt were wrong
so i encourage that and i want to thank
our sponsor here at
betterhelp.com slash griffin
you get 10 off all right
so somebody said something in the chat
about my clippers losing by 50
and i do want to talk about my clippers
they're my clippers i love the clippers
i've loved the clippers for a long time
i'm from l.a i love the clippers all
right i don't know what the hell is
going on with the clippers right now
they got tyloo i don't know if ty lue
was a good hair coach or not
i really don't know i feel like
lebron james is just that great of a
player
he's won a championship with what three
different coaches now
he's won a championship with three
different coaches and
mike brown has one coach and when he was
at cleveland that
the best records that guys ever had in
his career
the dude that came from uh what you call
it from the other country that they they
they hired whatever that
guy's name was he looked like he was a
good coach
it's just lebron james is just a great
player so i don't
know if ty lue's a good coach and then
we have all these issues you hear like
all this like
you hear that like mantra as harold and
and didn't like
paul george and and then paul george
wasn't playing well then
paul george freely admitted that he was
going through some stuff i think the
quarantine and
in the bubble was getting to him so he
wasn't playing well and then kawhi
leonard who
forced the clippers to give up
everything to get paul george
he chokes into game seven and he's not
necessarily a vocal leader that they
need
and now they're sitting here in this
position where it's like they gotta win
the championship this coming year or at
least
really compete for it because i don't
even think hawaii leonard's gonna come
back
and i think that that's gonna be a ding
on his reputation
and his and his legacy in my opinion
because we already know that that
toronto championship is bogus
you know kevin durant's not playing
uh michael what's his name um
thompson he goes out you know one of the
one of the
uh splash brothers he's got he's out and
then they win the championship so
you already got an asterisk on that
championship as it is
and so this is his time to be like
you're the man you're the best player on
the team klay thompson thank you you're
the best player on the team
it's time for you to like make it happen
you know and so then they lost by 50
today
50. what you're a professional nba team
you're not supposed to lose by 50
especially if you are you are supposed
to be a championship contender so that
really ticked me off michael thompson
was his father klay thompson is the son
michael thompson played for the lakers
won championships back in the day
in the magic era so
i don't know what's going on right now
and you know
we're gonna know right away in my
opinion we're gonna know
like in like three four weeks depending
on what their record is if they're
meshing we will see
if this iteration of the clippers can
really
make us feel like give us that
excitement of like oh we're about to go
to the championship so
oh no we'll see
and hello everybody out there if you're
here
all you guys that are listening live
thank you for being here and everybody
that's listening
later i appreciate you please leave your
comments and things and remember like i
said
um i'm doing a real world advice from a
grown-ass man next week
as the last one of 2020 so look out for
my instagram post for that
you know and so again i don't know
what's up with my clippers
i don't even like watching man if i'm
being honest and it's like
i don't know about you guys but i like
the bubble better
in terms of like how the court looked i
liked that
thing with people on the screen screens
i liked that version of the nba because
it still looked good and you still kind
of saw people
and i like that energy now they're
playing in
in their regular stadiums and you know
there's tarps or
they all got some different look but it
just feels like it's starting to feel
like
is this what life's gonna be and we're
starting to feel like we don't like it
that's just my opinion you know i think
we're looking at now like ah i don't
really like this
i don't like how this looks and let's
get this vaccine out and everybody take
it
and so we can like get back to games
transition this leads me into that so
you know i was talking about the vaccine
last week or even the week before and
then
you know i see the messages people send
and i was saying like i'm going to take
it you know i'll take the vaccine
i'm not i'm not necessarily worried
about it i'll take the risk i think it's
worth it
you know of course people have the you
know the conspiracy theorists about
vaccines and people like well
you know there's all this [ __ ] about
vaccines from my knowledge
has been debunked now then people send
you things about like
oh this is what's happening to some
people look some people are allergic to
some of the proteins that are in
vaccines but that goes with anything
like some people are allergic to to a
lot of things like latex for instance
for instance let's say you're allergic
to latex
just because you're allergic to latex it
doesn't take away the benefit of using a
condom
like condoms still have they're not
mutually exclusive using condoms
are good to prevent diseases and stop
pregnancy and whatever whatever your
positive whatever the positive column is
for condoms it's still positive
if you enter people in that are allergic
to latex it doesn't take away from
the positives of the condoms it just
means these people won't be able to use
condoms because they're allergic to
latex
that's the same thing with the vaccine
the vaccine the vaccines
for people that are not allergic to
those type of things it's gonna be fine
okay but there are certain people that
are gonna have some effects like i read
a thing where
one of the vaccines was messing with
people who have
what do you call it like some sort of
like cosmetic work done
like lip injections and things like that
but then when i read further
well that's natural because the vaccine
is is fighting against
foreign antibodies and so yes
it is causing a adverse effect with
people that got lip injections
but they have that it can easily be
remedied
but to me that doesn't mean oh my god
the vaccine is terrible
look what's going on with the vaccine
you know so
for all you people that are going to
send me messages about the vaccine and
all this kind of stuff it's like
i i believe in my logic my logic is
sound
the positive effects of the vaccine have
nothing to do with people that are
allergic it doesn't mean that the
vaccine is bad it just means that it's
not going to be good
for those people and it's not a large
number of people but you know some
people
have effects of you know what do you
call it
of the some of the ingredients in the
vaccine so look i hope my parents take
it i want my mom and my stepfather to
take it because i want them to be safe i
want them to be able to
like get out and because this is like
you know my mom's got dementia and this
is like the
the last parts of her life i don't want
her to be cooped up in their place
because she can't go out and can't you
know be breathed on and not live
i want them to live you know so i hope
they get out
get it out there for people and i want
all those frontline workers and
man you read up on these things you hear
about all of the like mailmen who have
gotten corona
all of the you know just all those like
sort of like those service workers and
frontline workers who
had to keep working they they've they're
suffering out there
i heard somebody say it was a good idea
i heard this when i was listening to
first take
stephen a smith said he heard it from
someone else but saying that like
what they should do for the super bowl
is give the vaccine to all of the
as many nurses and doctors and frontline
workers as possible
and then fill the super bowl stadium up
with them for free
you know like fly them all out have as
many of them as you can
come and be at the super bowl
and that'll be a great like hey we're
going to get back to normal it'll be a
good
that'd be a good look to get back to
normal all right oh guess what guys
[Music]
i'm just kidding thanks man thanks for
the super chats
and then what do you guys think about
everybody listening people listening
live and people listening like
the replays and stuff like i don't
really have a problem with like
the nfl like sports figures even
you know unless i'm in entertainment
business and so i would you know
i think some entertainers that provide
service
of the entertainment getting the vaccine
before
some regular folks get it too because of
all that it provides like you know
it's like the nba players
forget them so they're gonna they have
to get it but that
means that look at all the people that
are employed because
of the mba so that's why you have to
give it to them
and then you give it to them you gotta
give it to the referees you give it to
the referees you gotta make sure the
the people that work in the stadiums and
you know so then
this provides something it provides
something for society so
i think i don't i don't have a problem
with them like
jumping the line per se you know i think
that
there there's a privilege to it but i
think that i'm okay with it honestly
because
i see what it provides like thank
goodness we have this escape right now
of even watching sports
you know so i i translate that too to
like
you know like productions you know
people doing movies
and television shows that are always
you know always here oh we got a new
member too
joshua alvarez became a member
you could become a member too be an
egghead but anyways
i don't necessarily have a problem with
that
so i don't know how you guys feel about
that but you could tell me in your
you know you could tell me in the
comments
all right well let's finish off with
you know this relief the coveted relief
bill or whatever it is
you know so first it was like they were
going to send everybody 600
everybody tripping on 600 and rightfully
so
600 i don't care where you are in the
country
what you gonna do with that six hundred
dollars like are you paying your bills
are you paying your rent it's like a
one-time 600 something to me it's like
what are we complaining about just get
to 600
because i don't care how much money it
is like so now they're talking about two
thousand dollars right
is that go oh now i'm getting two
thousand dollars is that
paying your bills are you surviving off
that like
how many people that are listening right
now and watching right now
what's your writ you know what i mean
i'm sure a lot of you like
even if your win is 800 you got
roommates or you live in a single or you
live in a part of the country where the
rent isn't as high as la
but i'm just talking la all you people
that live in l.a
you don't got to be rich i'm just
talking about just regular ass rent in
la
that 2 000 gone it's gone
okay so you talking about two months
maybe but what about all the bills and
expenses that go on with that
so what i'm saying is we all need to
just shut up
because it's never gonna be enough money
to help people
it's never gonna be enough money to help
people right so this is just them go
here so even if it's just a 600
okay like give me this you know give me
the 600 dollars
like what what what and if it's 2 000
i'm not i don't even qualify for it i
don't think i didn't got to get uh the
one before
so there's certain people that are like
you know you're in a certain tax break
you shouldn't get it okay
and i agree with that but at a certain
point it's like
you're going to complain about the 600
because you want 2 000 or whatever the
amount is
and it's still not going to be enough is
my point
so i don't know man
and i'm talking about that as people are
sending me entertainment tips right
[Music]
here we go here we go
[Music]
um
you got your woo-boos all right guys
so that's my only event i wanted to uh
say about that but since we're winding
down 2020
um and i'm doing this live right now
we're in the live chat
if there are some live questions you
would like me to answer right now
i will answer live right now so if
you're in the chat right now
and you have a eric griffin question a
riffing with griffin question
or something that you want me to address
but we're going to take the last
10 minutes of the show right now and
address that and make sure you also guys
make sure you also watch me we have one
more episode of the potluck on twitch on
the crown channel
it's a show i'm hosting with the lovely
lisa malambri it's like we're showing a
bunch of like all the
different odds odds and ends and pop
culture stuff
that's on twitch it's like a talk show
and we're presenting it and we have one
more episode we
it was only a december run so that's
wednesday at eight o'clock eastern so
make sure you guys check that out this
wednesday on the crown channel
anyways so what you got what you got
guys
anybody let's go
i guess nobody has any questions
am i done with destiny
no destiny is a video game that i play
on
xbox it's just like first person shooter
type game i've been playing it for like
five six years
it is such an addictive fantastic game i
love it and the new version came out but
i'm just so addicted to call of duty i
love playing call of duty that
i haven't been playing destiny as much
but i will play it
i already gave adam i already gave my
review of wonder woman so you have to
rewatch this episode
and you'll see that i gave a whole
in-depth
review of wonder woman 84.
overall i thought it was okay but it
wasn't over it wasn't like
wow i i wasn't like wowed by it
somebody says to me how are you coping
with the craziness in the world at the
moment
it's hard i i don't know if i'm really
coping
i guess i am coping i'm doing what i can
i've readjusted i
game now you know look at me i'm doing
live episodes like this now
you know i'm i'm like you know a
homebody i'm trying to stay safe and i'm
trying to like
so that's how i'm coping with it but
it's tough i miss my friends i miss
hanging out
i miss going to movies i miss eating out
at restaurants man i just
i miss interacting with people i miss
meeting fans i miss like the meet and
greets at shows
i miss doing stand-up man i miss it i
miss being at the club and like
you know afterwards giving people hugs
man i'm a hugger
people will come up to me and we take
pictures and i got my arms around them
and we take these great pictures
and i just i miss all that you know it's
just it's
it's been tough and i have my moments
i'm just being honest with you i have my
moments where i'm just
really depressed about it you know and
then i just go damn well you know i i
don't i
i can't there's nothing i can do about
it so i just have to like make the best
of it but sometimes you get tired of
making the best of it and you just want
the best
you know what i mean so it is hard
that's how i deal with it
you know i deal with it by just
remembering that
you know i am still entertaining people
you know i remember
i have a beautiful fiancee who i love
dearly
and she's just been my rock and i really
appreciate her so
i just remember some of the good things
you know what i mean i still
talk to my friends i still you know what
i mean but again it's hard
so it is what it is
somebody says can you smoke a joint next
stream no i cannot because
i really don't i don't really smoke weed
i
i did start doing a little cbd
um cbd with a little thc so like
the most i like is like a 4-1 mix which
is like 20
and you know you count the numbers by us
like four so it's like if there's
one hit of thc and four hits of um
cbd that needs a total of five so that
would be 20
so so they have like i like i like that
percentage right there and then they
have the other ones you know 8 to 1
16 to 1 and all that kind of stuff but
like to me cbd is like
useless unless you got to have a little
bit of thc in there to give it a little
it's a little
the little spark that's the spark of
magic that you that you need
see what a stupid question would you
still do the podcast if you developed
bell's palsy from the vaccine
come on man yeah i probably would have
to
you know it would be bel
bell's palsy with griffin that's how i
have to do it
i have not somebody asked if i'm a film
worker have you been on set at all
no i have not been on actually have i
been on the set no i
actually i don't even remember now if
i've been on a set during these times
um actually i haven't been on a set i've
actually done a lot of online stuff
i've just been exclusively been doing
like online sitting here in front of the
camera
and doing stuff so that's uh
how i've been um making money and like
survive in that way
so but i hear like if you know it's like
it's a lot for them to like
you know set up the the you know make
sure it's safe
you know make sure everybody's following
the protocols you know
it's like you have to rely on other but
that's what we do when we drive on the
streets
look when you're driving in the street
you trust
that the other people driving in the
street are gonna follow the rules
when you're headed to a green light you
know
that the people coming opposite you
they're gonna stop okay you know they're
gonna stop
if you didn't trust other people you
wouldn't be able to drive
so that's how it has to be about covid
we have to hope
that people are being safe and when they
come to you
from their environment or you're working
in like a
studio set or something like that that
everybody's taking care of business
that's all that we could do we just have
to hope
you know we have to hope that that's
how it works you know what i mean so
yeah man i don't know guys
favorite british comedy that's not the
office
mark duffy also with a super chat too so
wait
we gotta check oh he's
when i was a kid i don't know if this
was british or not but i don't know if
you guys even know or the old people
that are watching right now
i remember benny hill did that
did that count as a british comedy i
don't know that too many british
comedies
because like you know i just like that
we take the british comedies and we make
them better
[Laughter]
and your face duffy
uh i am i thank you i like that people
are noticing
that i'm um looking slim it's just that
i've been eating better
i am not eating out at restaurants and
having a lot of fast food
so when you do that you naturally are
going to start to
lose weight if a lot of the weight was
put on by
eating terrible food so
that's that's where i'm at right now i'm
starting to you know eat better
you know i'm having more like i had a
salad for dinner tonight
for lunch then i had like chicken and
vegetables for dinner and that's just
how i'm eating and that's just
one of the ways but i also have to mix
in some more exercise
but it's difficult because i like to go
into the gym i like to go on so
like they have a lot of these like
indoor stuff now
like you can like you can like go on to
uh
your youtube and that kind of stuff so
i'm gonna start doing that kind of stuff
because we have an extra room now
that like i got into this big argument
with rachel i'm gonna finish off telling
you guys about this
it wasn't a big argument but it just was
stupid because
we haven't really moved in yet we
haven't we haven't unpacked everything
so
we had a bunch of boxes of stuff in the
living room it's on the
ground floor so she hits me up and goes
hey i want to make a video to send to my
family
so take all that stuff out of the living
room so i take all the stuff out of the
living room and i put it in the second
bedroom
because i need to organize it still
right then she comes home and she's mad
at me because i'm
playing video games i'm streaming i make
money streaming so i'm streaming but i
know what it really was she just wanted
me to spend time with her right
next thing you know i hear a lot of
ruckus in the hallway and she's moving
stuff out of the room because she's like
well
this is supposed to be my room my yoga
room i want to do yoga in here
and i can't and i want to do yoga and
tomorrow's my day off
i mean she just we got to do this whole
thing and i was like
what are you talking about if you would
told me to clear this room i would have
cleared it so we can't do a big thing
about it
she storms off i go in it takes me like
10 minutes i move all that stuff into
the closet
i take our yoga mat and i put it in the
middle of the room and there's nothing
else in there
all day today nothing no yoga
all day today i go to her later or later
right like about why before i started
this podcast and i go hey what happened
to the yoga
i thought you needed to do yoga i
thought it was like i have to do my yoga
and i just made fun of her and we
laughed about it and
that's why i love her because like even
when i hate her
she just has a way of like making me not
hate her anymore
you know and that's and that's really
the sign of a
good relationship i guess you know
because you're gonna have moments where
you're gonna be like i
can't stand what you're doing right now
in this moment right now i do not like
you
and then they turn around and give you a
hug or give you a smile
and it just all goes away and she
and she has that power over me to make
it all go away she'll just say
give me a 30 second hug and then you
know it just goes away
you know because i just got mad because
i was like all you had to do was tell me
to move this
but just be real that you're just upset
that i'm not spending time with you
right now and you're making a big
dramatic scene over nothing
you know and i hate that i can't stand
drama
but you got to let it go
you got to get it you got to let it go
you know and if you were
and i was streaming at the time too so
if you saw it live
where i had to leave the room and go do
some damage control that's what happened
yeah relationships are for sure a
love-hate relationship
it's just like and that's really what it
is when you just realize that you know
it's funny how the same person you
adore the same person that is the light
of your life
can also be the same person that causes
you to feel like
damn i just want to i just want to
yesterday i wanted to take her face and
cover it in honey
and stick it in a beehive that's just
how i felt at the time
you know what i mean
but that's the thing too like exactly
what
somebody in chat just said right now you
said you liked high maintenance
i do that's just part of who i am too
it's like so this
so so it's hard to be mad when somebody
high maintenance is acting high
maintenance
but that's part of the the thing the
heightened emotions that you feel when
you're with someone like that
you know but i feel like i'm pretty high
maintenance myself too
but uh you know i i yeah i can give it
you you give it to me you don't get it
right back and so and that's the thing
that she can't stand too she hates that
i'll be giving it right back so but
anyways guys
i really appreciate um
i appreciate you guys listening to uh
to griffin with griffin this week you
know let me get something good
let me get something good on here some
other music from some of the people that
have sent me
tunes if you want to send me some of
your music send me some music i'll play
it
thank you for listening
[Music]
all right guys thanks for being here i
hope you guys have a
safe and wonderful new year's make sure
you uh
just be safe out there all right don't
be going to a lot of parties
if you're going to be getting drunk
especially if you need if you're gonna
be drinking
just drink with your immediate family
man you don't want to put yourself in a
situation where you're gonna
you know put yourself and your family in
danger
especially anybody older in your family
or anybody existing conditions so
be safe out there i really appreciate
you guys being here
um i'm not always going to do it live
but while i was setting things up
getting everything together i said you
know what let me just go live i know
because this is how i do my pockets
anyway it's just free flowing and i just
do it i just sit in front of my thing
and do it
and that's it and that's when i except
for when i have like a guest right so
like this i'd rather share this time
with you guys so
[Music]
you know what i mean
and also don't forget remember thanks to
our sponsor
better help that's hclp betterhelp.com
griffin for 10 off i highly recommend
therapy if you're going through some
stuff and it's affordable
and it's accessible to you at home
but anyways thanks for watching we're
from griffin and i will see you all
next week
[Music]
you